[Music]
it's e3 2018 and we are here at the
Bethesda boof and I'm joined by none
other than Todd Howard hey welcome to go
in how's your show been so far
it just started so we'll see how they
take us so you had a pretty interesting
press conference let's start with that
the thing I want to ask about is for the
past few years you've set this precedent
of releasing announcing a game and then
releasing shortly after this was quite
different you announced a bunch of games
to games specifically with no release
date and kind of just said they're on
there in the works can you talk a little
bit about the kind of the reasoning
behind it and the thinking behind that
it's very unlike what you've been doing
for the past couple years yeah it was
definitely different and we went we went
back and forth whether or not we wanted
to do that because we still had you know
a lot of things that we were announcing
releasing right away where it's the ps4
and switched versions of shelter blades
is coming out right away 76 is coming
out in November but we we have a pretty
good sync with our fans and they kind of
already know like they see kind of
rumors and things and we felt that it
was it was just good to acknowledge him
we've said before you know we're doing
an Elder Scrolls six eventually but this
says it in a more a much louder way and
it puts an image to it in a tone to it
and we just felt that you know this was
the time to to maybe go in that
direction right the only you know
potential negative is I don't know when
we're gonna be able to show people those
games or talk about them again
so there might be a period that's a
little weird but people don't hear about
them and maybe that makes them anxious
in a new way
but we'll figure that out I think we're
still really great for us in the fans it
kind of is a huge double-edged sword
doing this right because you know what
people want they want the next Elder
Scrolls
see and now that you've asked that
you've put it on the stage and said it's
happening it's gonna be the thing that
people focus on what's your first
question right exactly yeah perhaps to
the detriment of other experiences like
do you do you foresee like oh we're not
gonna be able to control like giving a
focus that any other of our games now
that we've announced the elderscrolls or
how do you how do you kind of like deal
with that anxiousness and the
frustration that people might feel that
you know guys not speaking about in
depth well I think part of it too is 76
is a very different Fallout game right
where it has similarities is still
different and blades is a different
Elder Scrolls game right you want to let
people know that hey even though these
are different than what we usually do we
are still going to do what we usually do
right even though starfield is new its
single-player it's very next-gen there's
a lot of new things but it's more what
people would typically associate from us
but we like to try new things while also
really loving the more I don't know how
to phrase it like classic style right
Bethesda Game Studios right so like
touching on fallout 76 a lot of people
are gonna you know you have this new
vision you're coming at it from a new
angle but there's still people who they
know what they want from a Fallout game
even if you're presenting this new
perspective on it so for those people
people like me who I like the idea of a
multiplayer Fallout game but I kind of
still there's a voice - mind wondering
if it as someone who likes the classical
fallout experience will I be catered to
properly so for someone who knows
classic fallout Fallout 3 for example
onwards well those people be able to get
that kind of experience out of a
multiplayer for a game like this well I
can't answer that and say absolutely for
every Fallout player because there are
there are many there's so many things in
Fallout 3 or 4 New Vegas or the old ones
there's so many parts of those that
to say this is what I fallout fan likes
right you know I see all types so the
heavy NPC quest and dialogue system like
it clearly doesn't have that the
watching a lot of people play it on a
twitch or a mixer or whatever the stuff
they're doing a lot which is exploring
and leveling up and finding areas and
finding stories it has tons of that so
if they're like that like that part of
it and just doing that on their own it's
you know it really tickles that it is it
is different but it feels like when you
sit down and play it it feels like ball
three or four but it has a different it
has a little bit of a different loop
because you run into other players you
don't know what they're gonna do and
that's us once we started doing it it's
very very exciting but the other thing
I'd say is you know what clearly we're
fans of other franchises or things and
it is I understand some of the anxiety
in terms of when there is a new entry
you don't want that to be a missed
opportunity like people like what they
like and so we kind of keep that in mind
too but as developers and creators we
like to try new things and this is one
so I guess for a lot of people for you
guys it's a matter of pull out 76
doesn't tell you a story it's about you
creating your own story there's a lot of
we want to let the players create story
that's what they already do in our aims
that's what a lot of people like about
our games there definitely is a story in
this game you know what happened to the
people outside after the bombs fell
where are they right what are the new
threats in the world how do you solve
that and our designers have done a
really really good job with it and
they've had put in a very tricky
situation of how do we do the things we
like to do but all of the humans are
real people in terms of missions and
that kind of stuff is it like you've got
a finite number of main missions and
then they're like repeatable stuff
outside of that or is it just
there's a through-line like there is a
main questline and then there's like we
use it a host of side quests some of
those are repeatable there are events
you can join in those repeat so that
kind of structure is very similar to
what we usually have outside of the
events an event will pop up in an area
and that's something where you get a
prompt on the screen and then you can
join it if you want but this event is
going on so one of the things that
people go a lot of excitement out of and
questions is the nuclear element of it
where people can drop a nuclear bomb
after they do the hard work so at the
same time you guys were saying that you
don't want this to be a game where you
know you lose progress because you die
how do you get nuked and retain progress
like what is the thing how does that
when you die at all you pick a place to
respawn and you keep going death is
already unknowing enough there's no
there's no loss of items or it's lots of
times what is the kind of like
implication on the world of a nuclear
bomb being dropped there like it's it is
their permanence to that then after that
or a not permanent so still messing with
how long it lasts right but if you take
in the other things the world is really
big so it wherever you nuke it kills
everything in that area if they didn't
believe yeah so you could stay there
like I want to get news okay it damages
everything being built that was built
you can repair it
and but the main thing is it's fun is it
creates a high level zone so that area
the map now as opposed to us saying
we've designed these high level zones or
raids the players get to do it and of
the six regions they act differently if
you nuke the cranberry bog you're gonna
get very different creatures
you know flora and fauna in there but
you have to be high level to really deal
with the you know the fallout of that
area when that's going on right so the
other big thing that you talked about
was camp building so there's some
questions about that and you've
mentioned that you can like build
together can you talk a little bit more
about how that works like are you all
building your own structures and also
how do you move all your all your
settlements and that kind of stuff
between sessions and and surveys almost
but you guys talk about basically the
main part of that is we let you build
wherever you want there's around key
locations we don't let you build so
you're not messing with quests or things
that we have there right but again the
map is huge so you get a pretty big
space that you can claim and then build
in if you when you log off that stuff
goes away as well okay then when you log
back in we re put it down okay you can
also move it because I mean you haven't
people don't know where they want to
built they play the game a lot so if you
build in one place you can then go
somewhere else and say oh I like this
view I'm gonna move my camp and then you
can replace all the stuff and
you know there's a little bit of effort
in that but we let you blueprint you can
blueprint all of your structures and
stuff and then put those down kind of as
stamps let's really put it down oh cool
so moving on from fallout 76 you
announced elder scrolls plates yes and
you described it as a pure Elder Scrolls
experience what does that mean to you
and someone who may not be 150 million
we were the old scholars what does that
meet them well to us we go back to say
arena which is really a awesome but
glorified dungeon hat right so that
blade started there and then you have
full quests in a storyline in a hub when
you get those quests from the town it
will you either get a handcrafted
dungeon or it'll generate one and then
you play through that dungeon and some
of those dungeons are big outdoor areas
so the one thing it doesn't have it
doesn't have an open-world we may add
that in the future but it has very large
levels some of them are large some of
them are smaller for thick run throughs
so one of the not concerns but obviously
the older scrolls is a very hardcore
gaming franchise and they're the fans of
it usually follow wherever it is so like
a mobile game and then they you know
hardcore gamers see the word free and
they're like oh what does this mean can
you talk a bit about the monetization of
the blades and how it impacts the
experience of the game well we're still
messing with that there are a lot of
angles now that we can touch with that
and we're taking the same approach as
fallout shelter which we took a very
light monetization approach and it
monetized great so they think gamers
reward that they know when you're
gouging them or that they want to reward
you they don't mind paying for value and
so we don't want to have timers in
blades where you can't keep playing so
we're playing with some chess mechanics
like clash Royale where you find a big
boss chest and then you can use your
gems to open it or you might have to
wait but you can keep playing still earn
other rewards Cosmetics are really good
for that game you know to dress your
character up show it off in the arena
some other kind of XP speed-up so we
have a we have a number of different
vectors we're still looking at and
figuring out where the right balance is
where we feel good about it we're
providing value and you said that you
want to bring this game to as many
platforms as possible you have a
timeline for that and what's kind of
like your priority how are you
approaching what platforms to pick when
you even said VR at one point right yes
which is like that is spreading like
that Skyrim levels of like ubiquity for
this game it'll be more than that oh
really
whatever thing is because we made it
from mobile it can go on more devices
right automatically right it can go to
VR mobile it can go where Skyrim is
still a very you know it's made for a
console or a PC I could say yes we have
kind of a timeline but it you know
things happen I don't want to I don't
want to talk about it right now is it is
it kind of built in a way to be scalable
or will you have to make adjustment know
it's been built from the beginning that
way ok that's everything we knew hey
we're gonna take this because we did it
with shelter right and we kind of got
there and we said well from the
beginning let's architect blades to do
that and we you know it has all new
mobile backend for us that we can make
that cross-platform play work ok it
seems like more so than show blades
could like be kind of like the first
stepping stone into there's more what
you would associate with us right
okay so the other game that you had
discussed big one star field it's been
kind of floating around for a while how
did you feel to kind of get out there
and just say yes it's the thing that
we're working on it was weird I actually
have a hard time even saying the name
like when I hear you say it it's still a
little weird because we have internal
code names and you got used to that for
years of never saying the word star
field what was the code name for stuff I
can't tell you so that's a little bit
weird you're still getting used to it to
me okay that's interesting
how far along in development is it is it
like playable now or their part there
are a lot there are sections of it that
are very playable we we mess around for
a while and then we know like this is
the game we're making and we know that
now we know the game we're making
there's some specific design challenges
that we'll that we know we'll have to
deal with because we're doing some new
things but there are there sections of
it you can play and it's one of the
reasons work you know hey let's announce
it is where it's looking awesome so
we're really confident like this is a
game we're definitely doing we have
runway in front of us we know what's
happening you know if we're lucky to see
that soon perhaps at QuakeCon or
something like Raisa everyone should be
very very patient okay you said the
Bethesda is like uniquely positioned to
pull this off what does that mean like a
lot of people are probably thinking oh
it's it's gonna be a classic sci-fi
style RPG in the same vein of Fallout
the Elder Scrolls it seems like you want
to do you want to go beyond that and
explore different genres or styles of
gaming is it doing that or is it very
much what people expect now
it has what you expected more I would
say that I would say we have a team
that's worked together for a very long
time done some very big games done
different kinds of systems right some of
those we can rely on and then we can
push further we have a lot of experience
in the studio so we can be very very
ambitious and try some new things and
there's a level of confidence that we'll
be able to exercise how important is
kind of exploring other genres to you as
someone who's kind of got this kind of
leadership role within Bethesda Game
Studios you have a lot of other teams
that are kind of filling out the is the
kind of catalog with shooters and other
types of experiences but you know but
there's Game Studios it has kind of a
trademark type of game sure do you guys
do you like want to explore other genres
beyond that not specifically for
star-filled but like is there a bit more
is there gonna be a time when because
the game studios makes you know a kind
of a another tactics RPG or like a music
rhythm game who surprised me we like
what we like so the games that we have
made are the ones that we want to play
right we like big epic stuff we'd like
to find what you know fallout shelter is
probably the most different outside of
the range of what we do that we've done
right blades is even though it's a
mobile game is much closer right so
do 76 as close to what we do but it has
obviously new things so I don't really
know how to answer other than we are
very similar to our fans I think in what
we want to see out of games and we're
going to keep doing that while trying
isn't cool so one of the things that you
mentioned both for Southfield and also
the next Elder Scrolls games
you mentioned the phrase next generation
there's been some little bit of
confusion about whether you mean like a
next-generation engine that you're kind
of working on all next-generation
platforms can you provide like clarity
on when you say it's a bit above so is
it well if we assume that star field
wouldn't be releasing on ps4 Xbox one
and would that be the question or I
guess a lot of people the question okay
so you're actually there is a question
there okay cool there's a bit that way
okay does that mean I don't mean honest
I don't know the answer to that okay so
you're trying to figure out well I can't
absolutely say yes to that okay I mean
like it makes a lot of people will own
these current consoles by the time star
field is out so it makes sense for you
guys so also it does but we're not going
to limit the vision okay so if it's
important for the game to leave this
consoles behind you're willing to do
that
I wouldn't I'm willing to but it's not
it's not a priority right now I put it
that way
you animate when you're when you're
making a game you want to get the best
stuff on the screen and then you
optimize and you do things and if it
lands here we can cast a wider net great
but we can't then that we've done that
before if you're if we're to say that
you're focusing on building both in the
next Elder Scrolls and star field for
next generation platforms does that mean
those will be the only Bethesda Game
Studios was fallout 76 will be the only
Bethesda Game Studios game we'll get
until those or do you have other are you
thinking of other games that you're
working on in between time that right
now is our lineup will be laid out
that's that's the order okay
we're like the major release right 76
star filled out roles okay so Elder
Scroll 6 a lot of people will want to
know what exactly what stage it's a I
assume it's like a massive game and they
you know it's very early very very early
very early so it's in the concept and
design this is what it is this is where
it will be
here's some of the parts it'll have okay
cool do you have like that obviously I
was gonna save you have released a the
other timeline but like in terms of I do
your video and I would be foolish to say
I mean if you wanna feel free but like
in terms of vision what kind of what do
you want to bring new to it what get
watching what you're targeting you
because obviously a lot of people have
played Skyrim now you've got a bigger
audience than ever before like how do
you approach creating and you scar a new
Elder Scrolls game for all those people
I really don't want to there'll be a
time for that but I would say Skyrim
such a huge thing for him you know it's
not just us right it's one of the most
popular games in the world yeah and so
we've obviously taken our time with it
as opposed to jumping right into it we
we know what we want it to be and that's
gonna take time technology other things
that we need to fill to probably pull it
off and that's with that franchise
deserves have you considered going back
and remastering all the games I know
there's a lot of Morrowind fans out
there who will absolutely kill me if I
don't say something about it we're
actually more interested in working with
platforms to have a more win runs
backwards beatiful man yeah so that's
where we're as I like remasters I like
the I like the charm of the way it was
back then personally like when you watch
an old movie yeah and so I'm much more
interested in how can we work with
Microsoft Sony or PCs to make sure that
game works well did you want to play the
way it was you can install it and play
it and all of that as opposed to it's
that same game but it looks really
really different that's just my own
personal preference okay
final two questions the first one the
Internet is wondering that jacket that
you wore during the beeping did you buy
that yourself to the stylist pick that
out for you where did you get that
jacket I bought it on Soul revolver
so revolver right sight is there you go
you've got a free plug for Soho
finally have you seen this video
I didn't know
[Music]
pretty good a great place
how'd you feel it would you want me to
send you that I can send you guys pretty
cool it's great yeah sweet Todd I'll
play that whenever I feel down you know
cool you're wearing all like I'll load
that up you like you look your hair
looks exceptional you're in a great
jacket you've got perfect lighting and
like your brand-new gaze it's just
superimposed over and it's the who like
that is great like motivational sigh
yeah it is yeah perfect
Todd thank you thank you it's great
speaking I have a great show
[Music]